- Welcome to the "Next 25."
I'm your host, Dwyane Wade.
And today I get an opportunity to talk
about the future for some of the game's brightest and best.
We wanna talk about what we call "pipeline."
But we're in this space right now
where you have individuals becoming famous
before they have a driver's license.
- Shady Baby.
- [Chuckling] My daughter.
- [Laughing]
- She ain't even spoke too many words,
and she was already famous, right?
What do you guys think about that
from the standpoint of the world that we live in in sports,
that a young kid in high school can become famous?
How do you deal with that?
How do you handle that at a young age?
- I feel like nowadays social media is the top of the top.
Like, everybody goes to social media to look at things.
And guys now, like, are dunking at 13, 14 years old.
- Nasty.
- You pull a dunk out in the game at 13, 14, they post it
and you go viral.
- They be having millions of the followers, 500K.
All these people commenting on their life.
They gotta live up to expectations at such a young age.
They come out with rankings with kids
that class of 2027, 2028.
- [Chuckling]
- They're, like, how old is that?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- How old is that?
- It's crazy.
- You don't know what this kid can be.
- Instagram famous is real.
♪♪♪
My name is Chris Johnson,
better known as NBA master trainer.
I'm located here in Los Angeles, California.
Just because you're Instagram famous doesn't mean
that you're prepared to play in the WNBA or NBA.
If you really go look at the track record of people
that have had success from a social media period
and continue that success, it's very, very slim.
I think social media's gonna be around.
It's not going anywhere.
So it's really important that we provide the necessary tools
for young players coming up to understand
that social media is their new resume.
- Is it good for our game, though?
- I don't…
- Or is it bad for our game?
- I think it's bad.
- Yeah.
- I think it goes back to the highlight thing.
Like, you don't actually know if someone's good.
Because if you put together a highlight reel, like,
it's obviously gonna be the best stuff.
- Right.
- And then, you know what I mean?
And then they have, especially the really young ones,
they have all this pressure.
And to have, like, millions of people disappointed
in you because you're not as good
- Right, yeah.
- at 13 or younger, that's hard.
- I agree with you.
I feel like it's a bad thing.
- As somebody who was, like, not highly recruited,
when you see that,
- Mmhmm.
- I feel like that motivates you.
- OK.
- You know what I'm saying?
Like, when I see, you know, kids my age
or younger than me getting, like, all this love,
then that makes me wanna go harder.
You know what I'm saying?
- Right, yeah.
- That makes me, like, I wanna be right there.
You know what I'm saying?
So for me, I think there's a good and a bad to it.
But the era that we grew up in, like, Ballislife,
Hoopmixtape,
- Yeah, yeah.
- all that stuff, coming out with mixtapes,
kids are they 14?
- Yeah.
- You be like,
"Man, I gotta get in the gym."
- When I played, I didn't get to see anybody.
- Yeah, right.
- Unless I see them on the—
- Yeah, unless you seen them in person.
- Right?
And so the game has evolved now
that you can see a 14-year-old, right, doing stuff.
And you like, "I gotta get on that level."
- Yeah.
- I never seen that.
You know, I didn't know who was the...
I heard some name, Darius Miles.
I'm like, "Who is Darius Miles from East St. Louis?
- [Chuckling]
- "I don't know who that is."
- Right.
- I never seen him until I got a chance to play
against him or play with him.
Right now, you can go on to see, you can see an eight-year-old right now
that's gonna play in the league
- Right.
- in a couple years.
And you go, "OK."
- Yeah, exactly.
- I know his scouting report.
- My eighth-grade year,
that's when, like, that's when I first got on social media.
Cameras came to my games and started recording me play.
And then I ended up getting an invite to, like, USA.
And that's when my journey, I guess,
began to kick off after that.
- When I came out, it was like,
you go to high school for four years.
You go to college for four years.
And then hopefully you get drafted, right?
And that is what someone would have told me
if I said, "How do I get to the NBA?"
- Mmm.
- That's the path.
If a kid come up to you guys today and say,
"What is the easiest, the most secure path to get
to the NBA or to get to the W?"
What do you tell 'em?
- Tell 'em to go to college.
- You tell 'em to go to college?
- I feel like college gives you that platform
where you can just really succeed.
I always been that college route.
Like, when they told me about the G League, I said,
"Nah, I ain't doing that.  You can just throw that away."
- Right.
- I said, "I'm going to college."
They changed the whole trajectory of what I wanted to do.
They said they wanted to put me
at point guard, different things like that.
Me just playing defense, being in that system,
being long, athletic, being able to show what I can do.
- I think college, the traditional route,
will still always be the dominant,
maybe the safest route because of development.
It takes so long for the true brain to develop.
Some people are, they grow later. They develop later.
Like, their body changes.
And believe it or not,
if you look at a lot of successful people,
it's not how fast they can get there. It's the journey.
- I wasn't a highly recruited kid growing up.
Iowa State was my first high major offer,
and I knew that's where I was going right away.
All my friends and family thought I was gonna redshirt.
I ended up starting every game
besides the first game of the season.
- Wow.
- I got to go to the USA with these guys
before my sophomore year.
And that's when I was really like, "I think I'm a pro."
- I ended up going to prep school.
Once I went to prep school at Mount Zion in Baltimore,
everything changed.
I didn't have no offers before that.
Dayton ended up coming to watch me play
and gave me a scholarship right then and there.
And I was, I went on a visit there
and knew right away, like, I belonged there.
But I redshirted my first year, played my second year,
and then I went to a Nike Skills Academy camp.
Once I went to that camp, I was like, OK,
now I feel like I got a chance to make it to the next level.
- I was a little more highly recruited.
I got my first offer in eighth grade
to Mizzou
- Yeaah.
- from Missouri.
And I wanted to, like, sign there right away.
I'm like, "I got my first offer."
And I really, like, credit my parents. They did a great job.
My dad's like, "We're gonna take all our visits."
Blah, blah, blah.
And when UConn recruited me, it was super exciting
cuz, you know, they're awesome.
- Mmhmm.
- But I originally didn't wanna go there
because they're so big.
I'm like: "I wanna beat UConn. Everyone goes there."
- Yeah.
- And then I took my visit there, and they convinced me.
[Wade and Collier laughing]
It was just, like, at that point I knew I wanted to play
in the W. And they have so many players there,
and they do so well.
I knew, I kind of treated it like a business thing.
Like, I knew going there was gonna get me
to the next step that I wanna be at.
- College outside of education,
because some of y'all just go in
for a year and y'all outta there.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- Y'all ain't get no education.
- [Laughing]
- But I feel like you're learning how to be an adult.
- Yeah.
- You're learning how to be on your own.
You're learning how to wash clothes.
You're learning, like, all the things that you may, some kids may not have done
by being at home with their parents.
Now you're learning it's all on you.
And so before you get to the NBA level
or the professional level,
you have learned some things about how to be an adult.
- Honestly, I feel like college is the last time
that you're on a true team because
when you get to the league, like, you get people traded midseason.
Like, you don't know if you're gonna be there from year to year.
- [All expressing agreement]
- That's the last time you feel, like, so a part of something,
where you feel like you're so in the trenches
- [Murmuring agreement]
- with that group of people.
- And when you get to that March Madness,
I think the boost in the March Madness…
- Yeah, that March Madness.
- Ain't nothing like that March Madness.
- March Madness.
- Yeah.
- Ain't nothing like that college experience.
You know what I'm saying?
- You got to have the college experience.
- It's not the same.
- Yes, like, you're talking about adulting and all that stuff.
Yes, that is a—
- I am shocked that y'all said, everyone's like,
college, college, college.
- Twenty-five years from now, we'll be still seeing players go
to college where they're one-and-done,
two years and done or play all four.
They will still have the same opportunity
as the players that go an untraditional route.
And the untraditional routes
to me are in still, like, a beta phase.
It's still unknown too what the failure rate is.
Both routes could meet the end route,
but I'm still a traditional route-runner because I believe
that young people need an opportunity to be young.
And some people can go the untraditional route
maybe because of circumstances.
- Now you have G League, right?
Obviously, you have overseas. You have the Ignite team.
You can be like Scottie and go to seven high schools.
- [All chuckling]
- We've given all these opportunities
for our basketball players to be able
to, you know, have an opportunity to reach their dreams. It's more
than just going to college for four years.
How does this evolve?
Where do we go from here?
- I feel like resources now is a lot different
- Yeah, it's crazy.
- than it used to be.
I feel like there's a lot more people in this world
that have the in on things.
There's mentors that you can go to
that know people that know people.
And it's, like, I feel like nowadays
it's just a matter of who you know.
Like, you know the right person, you gon' be good.
And if you have talent, you gon' be real good.
- With the Ignite program,
you're gonna have to be probably one
of the top three, four, five players in your class.
So it makes it exceptional.
And it is geared around about 10 players.
And that system is truly built
for player development and mental development.
I think there could be a few more pathways.
I don't know when the CBA is up,
but being able to go straight to the league again, you know,
I would like to see that changed also.
And just so it can switch it up.
But that does put the curve in everything.
- Once they change that college rule,
and we get money in NIL deals,
- Man.
- it's way different now.
- I'll be watching my brother get all these deals
at Kentucky. I'm like,
"Can I get something when I was in college?"
- I'm rationing my per-diem check.
- Shoutout Jacob Toppin.
- [Chuckling]
- So is that where we're going,
where the NBA is not the all-end, be-all?
- [Chuckling]
- Or the W, right?
It's like kids growing up, it's, like, the W is still young,
so it is still growing, right?
- Yeah.
- The NBA is kind of older, so it's kinda, like,
"Oh, I can make money.
"I don't need to go to the league
- Right, yeah, yeah.
- to make money."
"I can make money in high school."
- I think that's where I was going before the NIL deal.
Like, I heard a lot of people talking about playing overseas
instead of going to college.
- Mmhmm.
- And then we can't go into the draft until we're, like, 22.
But now with the deals, you can make money there.
I don't know if it's gonna change.
- With the NIL, with your ability to be paid off
of your own personal brand and likeliness,
you're gonna see a lot of people not make it to the NBA
because they're being paid a lot earlier.
And that can actually take away
from the hunger depending on the individual.
I don't think making it
to the NBA is the end be-all.  It's something that you want.
I work with the best players in the world
and some people that make an extreme amount
of money playing basketball.
They still get up…5 o'clock a.m.
They still get up and do it over and over again.
You have a better chance
at doing other things than making it in the NBA.
And that's how special those guys are to that craft.
And that's how special they are to being on that stage
and being able to perform.